مع دخول العشر الاواخر لشهر رمضان المبارك
استفاق السودانيون على صوت الرصاص بدل
الاذان وسط تصاعد حده الاشتباكات بالاسلحه
الثقيله بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع مواطنون تراكم نازلهم وذكرياتهم
وهرعوا الى اماكن بعيده من العاصمه
الخرطوم خوفا من القصف والرصاص الذي لم
يتوقف لحد الساعه لجنه اطباء السودان
اعلنت عن ارتفاع عدد ضحايا الاشتباكات الى
56 قتيلا واكثر من 600 جريح منذ بدء
النزاع الذي دخل يومه الثاني
في وقت اعلن الجيش السوداني سيطره قوته
على قواعد قوات الدعم السريع ومقراتها في
سبع ولايات قائلا ان ساعه النصر قد اقتربت
شوارع العاصمه الخرطوم اصبحت وكانها ساحه
حرب سمائها الزرقاء غطتها سحب الدخان
الكثيفه وصوت الحياه في المدينه تحول لقصف
ودمار